My breast lump caused nipple retraction. It has also attached itself to the skin.
Right above the nipple, the lump is right there at the surface of the skin,
and it's hard as a rock, at least what is attached to the skin and can be easily felt by
local practitioner, not a doctor, so that the dead tissue can calcify, and that means baby
assigned at the lump is dead, at least right there. Is that true? It can be, I don't know that if it
will calcify or just be fibrous tissue, you would be able to tell me an x-ray or an MRI would
be able to show that if it's calcified, and if it is or just fibrous tissue, that is assigned
in its dead, so yes, that is true. To complete the question, it says, it feels like it could
easily be pushed out through my skin. I know that's going to be a mess if that happens.
If it does that, is it best to go ahead and apply black sand to speed the process? Will the nipple
retraction replicate the process? It can be a very complicated process, and if it does break through
the skin, I've had many women that have used black sand on it at that time, it can, the real issue
you have to watch for is if it's going to bleed, it tends to be a very, very long and seemingly
endless process, so we should talk if that does happen, because there's pros and cons to doing
black sand at a fairly large tumor.